what shook you the most plot wise when
you were like whoa this is intense
probably hannah being dead the whole
time
that that that blew me away when we were
talking about it in the writer's room i
was like
what she was dead the whole time
it's such an intense show there's so
many layers to it the character
is dealing with a trauma around her and
internal trauma all these things that
are going on
what was it about this character in
particular that made it more difficult
for you to do that than in other times i
think a lot of it was the physically
rigorous aspect of it the amount of
information i was holding at my head
at any given moment because we were
shooting like
i hadn't ever done anything quite this
rigorous i hadn't worked
quite as long hours continuously over
time
there was that and just the time in my
life i'm 25 i'm now moving
from having worked consistently pretty
consistently for about three years
um but i haven't had much time to
you know process whatever that means
um adjust to
to that change and i feel like that that
had a lot to do with it i don't
i don't also danny just being
um so
you know she's big she uses she's
she's she's also very anxious so when
i'm doing all of those anxiety attacks
i'm my i'm not having an anxiety attack
i'm sure you do
but i'm shaking and i'm crying
and that's that's like exhausting in a
very specific way
you know you know how you feel after you
have a big cry but i'm doing that
over and over and over and over again um
is it
does it because is it it is worth it you
know i get to watch them be like
yeah okay it's worth it but at the time
i think i had i had a little time
a harder time understanding that we
place
so many labels on people still like
we're like
you're like this so cool so that's your
label and you stick to that label and i
think labels are so
damaging in so many ways to people and
their identity in themselves
how's that played out in your own life
this idea of labeling and whatever
aspect that could be
for instance i have a dd
and that label did not suit me i felt
you know i i was six years old or seven
years old and being told
you are going to be at a higher rate of
you might not even be able to like well
read and write well
you're going to have a higher rate of
incarceration higher rate of drug use
higher rate of like lots of medical
problems it's going to be very hard for
you to live a healthy lifestyle like
all of these things and i just looked at
that label and i was like
[Music]
no that that's not
that's not me in the band
i have add i have add
severe add um whatever that means you
know and
it affects the way i live the way i
think the way i process information
or don't process information and it was
so damaging to me at that age because it
didn't do anything for how i defined
myself it only allowed other people
to make assumptions and feel like they
had the answers
to something far more complex than add
people with add
are very different you know there are so
many i remember going to like an add
support group and being like
i don't like these people you know and
why should i
but that's that's that kind of label
then there's label that suggests more
community and stuff like that and
i don't know but the add thing i can say
that those kind of like
mental diagnosis i feel like they often
do so much more for the
people treating you than it does
to the actual individual having an
understanding and feeling empowered
within their identity
if i had listened to people i wouldn't
be where i am if if i had
if i had thought of it as a deficit i
wouldn't be here you know
and i feel so strongly that i kind of
want to be a voice within that community
what's so amazing about
what you're saying as well and i think
this is so remarkable
about you as a person is you've taken
this thing
and you've just used it to empower you
and you're like
i am empowering myself i'm gonna do this
for me
and now you're out there slaying it on
netflix
like honestly like i feel like you
should be so proud
of that that you've taken that thing and
that label and used it to empower you in
so many ways as well
i don't feel like i found it empowering
until i've gotten to
this point you know until i've like
exited academia and
found my way into having a career and
making a life for myself
i think i kind of always questioned that
it would be the thing that just
picked me up because people weren't
particularly accommodating or
understanding about it
people tried to tell me about my own
brain and my own mind my entire
life and i think that that's really
destructive
but then it's just like now
now i can see it and i feel like i need
to talk about it because
i need other young people that
are struggling in school or
struggling with their emotions and their
feelings to
know that it's normal that they're not
deficient or defective
i wish the educational system in this
country catered to like
more people and that i
had more teachers that had the tools to
understand and
and help me and it's so great being an
actor because
i don't play labels i play people and
that's the goal
you can either uphold all these
assumptions and labels and stereotypes
or you can do things that divert them
and that's a show and my show
you know i think does a pretty good job
of
bending those things and and and making
us
question and even just seeing things
differently i hope
i think that's so true that's so
powerful what you just said in that
sense and that leads me on so well to
this is not a love letter
it's so important that someone like you
is lending
your voice and your message to this kind
of message
one really spoke to you about
this project in particular what made you
want to be part of it
i mean i agreed to be a part of it
before i understood
what it was i i agreed to be a part of
it because my
close friend told me
that she'd written something and
that she she wanted me to be there
and that a bunch of
other women are going to be there some
people i knew some people i didn't know
and then i i went into the room and she
read the poem to me for the first time
and i had
been in school
with this woman for four years
and i didn't know this story
it's it's really powerful isn't it it's
it's really
not only her sharing her experience but
the way that she
articulates herself the way she tells
the story
i i i i i agreed to do it because it was
isabelle
because she's one of the best people i
know
um and then afterwards i
found out that i was very very very
lucky to be
asked to be a part of something
extremely powerful and informative
i feel so strongly that this
conversation around abortion is being
held by a bunch of people who don't know
about what it is to have
that experience and she's an authority
on that and so she needs to be listened
to
the only way people like i know i'm
trying to talk politics
the only way people who you know justify
life at conception is through some
christian
standard it it it's it completely gets
in the way of the separation between
church and state
and yet you still see in this story
that the morality taught through
christianity still
made this woman question whether or not
you know
god loved her you know
we we we have our own morality
the government shouldn't be defining
that for us
well i think i've said i think you're
amazing about 20 million times
you're also amazing this has been great
thank you so much for taking the time
out to speak to me